two
all right
welcome everybody to h3tv today we have
um
a good episode i think
kind of depends on the callers
yeah i don't know i always think that
like you know it's up to it's up to us
to make it you know oh really there's
the pressures on me well my pressure's
on me you think it's on you why is it on
me too a little bit well we're working
together to make something out of you
know hey come on what's going on out
there
out of whatever happens someone's
slamming stuff in the background i hope
they're having a good time
um
i'm having trouble with the head
i think you look great because i feel
like
i feel like you're trying to out gecko
me the deflation is part of the charm
though it is you know like people enjoy
seeing imperfections in people because
also my my neck is kind of tucked in by
the way the number because you could
show the number or do you like it kind
of like floating
a classic mistake that people typically
do is they they do it like this and it's
like a bib like i see that on like
all the time when people like will post
like tick tocks or whatever themselves
wearing a gecko
but you got to make you got to make sure
you tuck it in oh see i i was tucked in
okay yeah no that's that's how you want
to do it okay good
so i'm here with lyle forever aka the
geck gekko
he is teaching me his gecko ways
uh for a little bit of a collaboration
here
the gecko is a bit of a uh
he is a bit of a psycho
analyst i would say that gekko is and he
uh i'm talking third person we're
talking about you
uh you take calls i do
and you listen you listen you give
advice we learn
is that right do you want to admit do
you want to add to that i would say i do
a lot of listening um
you know i'm not a real therapist
oh you're not i'm not a real therapist
oh
you didn't tell me that before we like
to troll we'll uh
well well i am a real uh well okay so
i'm not a real therapist wait are you a
real gekko well that's the other
question i was good is am i real gecko i
like to leave it up to viewer
interpretation if you and your
perception of reality and your
perception of me would like to view me
as a real gecko i don't want to
influence i don't want to ruin your
perception of this so it's up to view
orientation if you would like to believe
that i'm well hold on can't we do that
about you being a therapist
i guess theoretically but then i guess
you would also in your perceptual
reality have to believe that it's not
illegal for me to pretend that i'm a
therapist that's a legal issue yeah
so if you believe you're a real
therapist make sure that your lawyer
shares that i mean no one cares if
someone tries to sue me like i think
they will look ridiculous bringing me
we're gonna have to be careful with the
advice we give
because unlike you i am a real therapist
oh really where did you go to school
cornell that's awesome
what did you learn there
i learned about the human mind
what's the most interesting thing you
learned at cornell about the human minds
well
the thing about the human mind that's
fascinating is that it's um
the brain is is very it is actually very
soft it's like a jello you could poke
your finger right through the brain
do you think the brain is chewy
no i think it's right it's actually it's
like jello it is the only reason you see
brains in a uh
you know a solid form is because they're
treated with chemicals but if you were
to flop my brain on this table right now
it would just
if you had the opportunity to like eat a
brain if it was like an animal brain and
like everyone around you was doing it
and it seemed like it was okay would you
would you take the opportunity no i
wouldn't
i respect that would you
um i mean i can't say how i'd feel like
because in the moment i might feel
differently than how i would answer yeah
i might get caught up in the moment yeah
but i try not to i'm a vegan really yeah
for a week one week okay how's that been
going good
so brain is not vegan no
you could make like an artificial sort
of plant-based brain but i don't think
it'd be the same
i don't know there's a big market for
that one
but a lot of people eat monkey brains
i've heard that you know you know
there's like tribes there's like rare oh
[ __ ] i showed my hair a little what the
hell lizards don't have hair dude you
know there's like uh actually like
horrible fatal diseases you can get from
from humans eating other human brain
really yeah
like really messed up uh you should not
eat
human brain it's very dangerous well
then i guess whoever has eaten the human
brain that must be really delicious for
them to
be willing to contract the disease
i don't think they know that about that
risk who are eating the brain well they
had to fight well someone had to have
eaten it for them to figure out for sure
yeah for sure
for sure for sure
so um let's see we have calls lined up
uh so these host cues these are ready
dan
theoretically theoretically
we haven't taken calls in about two and
a half years um but we tested pretty
thoroughly before the show so okay um
let's see here this is hunter from
georgia oh beautiful hunter
go ahead we have two geckos and one
question how can we help you hunter
hello to geckos
hello hunter how are you today
how are we
i'm i'm okay how are you
uh pretty spicy i'd say just very spicy
why spicy why did you choose the word
spicy that's a very specific way to
describe how you're feeling
i don't know just a very exquisite day
when i can see two human geckos very
alive and well on twitch
under the h3 banner proudly serving
their nation and
presenting themselves to the foot
do soldiers know what a portfolio it's a
soldier who doesn't have a car
um not in like no that's not right well
how what is the foot soldier i thought
do you know what wikifeed is no okay
we'll move on it's an internet thing
yeah okay
go ahead hunter you have a question
yeah
how do i approach your roommate who i
know is the one leaving behind messes
um
can we get more details about the messes
because obviously there's scales of
messiness exactly exactly is it a couple
dishes is it like are they tracking dirt
in the house how bad is the mess
so it's like
three roommates
uh other than me and a house
and uh so there will be dishes that
stack up
and bugs will start coming in and i know
that none of them are my dishes and i
don't want to say anything to the guys i
just don't know how to approach it why
don't you want to say anything to them
what's your apprehension do you think
that they'll like get upset with you
that you're upset with them
well as you can hear from my like shaky
voice i relate to ethan and that i'm
very anxious most of the time pretty
neurotic
so i guess um when it comes to
situations with confrontation i don't
know what to do
ethan if so if this were happening to
you like would you would you feel
confident enough to just tell your
roommate to clean up the damn mess
or do you relate to hunting hunter um
why did you say that about
me i don't know you've uh spoken highly
about your well not highly about your
mental health and your anxiousness
about how you uh over analyze everything
you say sometimes uh you know that was
back on frenemies with tricia so maybe
you've changed by now
but um right i think you're describing
maybe
i think maybe you have a problem if i'm
being uh if i can make an assumption
with assertiveness maybe
do you have a problem with asserting
yourself
definitely right
how old are you
uh i turned 21 next week
yeah i think with the youth there is a
problem of course with with the
confidence to assert yourself
i will say when i was your age i had i
had more problem asserting myself part
of the problem is because you don't know
that you're right there's there's you'd
say well maybe i'm wrong maybe they can
leave a dog [ __ ] on the they can't take
a human feces on the kitchen corner
right
there's doubt that zach
[Music]
right i feel like as you get older you
you know have been in this situation
before and you are more assertive of the
fact that you are correct that exactly
it is not appropriate to leave a dog
[ __ ] in the in the sink
i'm not talking so hard you gotta do it
so hunter let me get some information
about your living situation how many uh
housemates do you have
uh three
and they're all bad
um in different areas yes regarding the
cleanliness they're they're all
kind of dropping the ball there
like they'll keep their personal spaces
clean but like you know all the combined
space is kind of just messy
like just the kitchen you have to move
stuff to clean up to uh cook sorry
is there anything you think your
roommates don't like about you
um
yeah that's a tough question
uh probably that i have no opinion about
things and i say okay
you think they don't you think they are
upset well okay so if your roommates are
upset you think by your passiveness
you're presented now with a great
opportunity to be assertive
so this is your chance to
to prove yourself as as having an
opinion as being assertive
seems like a way that could be a way to
find my voice
do you what is your fear do you is there
a fear that this is going to backfire on
you
if you ask them to hey guys just let's
clean keep it a little cleaner
it's just that it's not a very large
space and you know it's four guys and i
don't want there to be any you know like
behind the scenes aggression because
that can just turn you know really
uncomfortable really quickly because
nothing may be said in front of each
other but there's just this unknown
tension
that would come along with a situation
like that that i would rather not have
well this is why you have to
be honest with your roommate because
this is you know not saying anything
that's how these tensions boil
right behind the scenes and you don't
want them boiling behind the scenes i'd
rather speak up and be wrong than be
muffled and be wrong that's greg paul
beautiful
you know uh gecko has a point there
really really what you want to do is
the longer you you you're going to start
to fester
about these dirty [ __ ] creeps
do your roommates drink a lot
uh
i i
i see alcohol in the fridge i don't i'm
never there if they're drinking
they're drinking with other people
definitely not me
is there resentment there that i detect
oh no
i mean i have like my own group of
friends and i don't
maybe i'm just uh i don't associate
enough with my roommates and that's why
i feel uncomfortable
interesting so these aren't these aren't
your direct friend groups they're really
just your housemates
yes
okay do you wish you were closer with
them
not really
well i just i want it to be like a
relationship that's professional but
also you know
at the same time kind of relaxed would
you describe a relationship between
roommates to be professional how would
it
no
it's definitely i i i you're i it's
definitely a different kind of
relationship i don't know if it's a
professional it's cordial cordial yes
well seeing as they're not your
immediate friend group i'm going to say
that you have even less to lose
when you're going to politely ask them
hey guys
you know
let let let let's
let's do this very little at stake yeah
there's very little at stake if they
were your real friends i would i would
be more concerned about the dynamic
but you know i would just i would just
tell them
and what how would you just how would
you
word it oh man
well hunter what's the truth
good question what's the truth hunter
you were where are your friends where
are your friends
my personal space
is a mess therefore i do not leave a
mess in the uh
combined space
so it could be
i'm i don't know
hunter pretend the other guys are
definitely an empathy hunter
pretend that me that we geckos are your
friends housemates not not friends
your cordial
roommates acquaintances acquaintances
housemates acquaintance housemates we've
all gathered we've assembled here for
you to tell us something hunter
tell us
as as straightforward and passionately
as you possibly can right now
what is on your mind
guys
geckos
the kitchen is a mess
and we are starting to have pests
now i would like to continue living here
so could we please
just please today clean up the kitchen
you know hunter maybe hunter i i i'm so
glad that you brought that to my
attention i didn't even realize that i
was making this mess and i didn't
realize it was bothering you so much and
i
appreciate so much that you brought this
to light instead of silently resenting
me because now i'm given the opportunity
to to write this wrong so thank you so
much for being honest with me
um i have a comment
who the [ __ ] do you think you are
you are such a bad housemate you
literally ignore me and now you're
coming to me on this beautiful sunday
afternoon telling me to clean the
kitchen i mean this is
and you're threatening to leave i mean
this is passive aggressive dude why
don't you just get out and find a new
place to live
um
wow uh thanks i'll think about that uh
who do you think you are thank you so
much for calling hunter thank you hunter
i think we were helpful to him i think
so too i think he's he's gonna
go do it now it's a lot to
chew on yeah yeah i mean
you know he's he seems like a good guy
from what i know about
um
let's see
this one's about if you should try
triller
do you know what trailer is i've heard
trailers like the the new tick tock
right yeah it's horrible i don't know
anything about it so the guy that owns
it like falsified me too documents to
fire his ex-president
and also he his ex-partner for uh like
accused him of running a ponzi scheme
by variety oh wow he refuted it though
just to be fair he's also suing me oh
he's suing you yeah that's why i'm like
do you think you're going to win yes for
sure sick
um i don't want to make this all about
me but i'm going to take this call let's
do it
jules
um
go ahead
oh hi there uh hi there he's a
big fan been big fan for years me and my
wife um how are you doing
good what about gekko
oh yeah yeah i mean
this is my honestly my first time i get
it i get it i don't understand i mean
yeah so far i really do enjoy what you
think
thank you enjoy what you've been saying
as well
i think we both have very little
information about each other but i think
that that information is suffice enough
for us to build
a cordial relationship
something to build off of absolutely
solid foundation um jules can we help
you with some issue concern or question
uh well
the main thing i've been a little bit
curious about is triller
i'm wondering if i should give it a try
honestly because i've been seeing some a
little bit of shady stuff recently like
i saw an article in the very reputable
publication called variety that the ceo
was accused by his former business
partner of running a ponzi scheme
so i guess i'm wondering if i should pry
the app out give it a give it one star
maybe to five stars i'm just wondering
well jules i'm so glad you asked
i would say the same thing i would my
answer would be the same for any
application which is try it
see how you like it
and then based on your experience and
the information you have about the owner
ryan kavanagh
give it a rating of one to five give it
a rating of one star
or more is that kavanaugh like kavanagh
kavanaugh no relation oh okay but same
name okay so jules i would definitely
recommend trying it but uh definitely
give it a one star
or more
i see i see okay because i was i was a
little turned off by it at first i mean
he kind of looks like harvey weinstein i
don't know if anyone else thinks so but
yeah i've noticed that too i don't i
don't see it
all right thank you so much jules i hope
that we were uh
jules do you do you think you look like
any particular celebrity
oh wait you hung up on him i hung up
jules is gone good i was just going to
let it oh i'm sorry
i just wanna you know
here i'll let you
um
i'll let you pick the next one
see anything in here good uh
let's see chelsea from michigan i should
not read them aloud i don't want them to
good all right chelsea permission
looking for career advice about doing
youtube
streaming really shy about it
what are you what are you feeling
into
investing in stocks are we qualified for
that i have nothing for that um advice
applying for jobs
question from his mom she found a
receipt of his brother's
floor that said anal probe let's do the
london one
wow man
is this real this is something we need
to suss out if this is a serious call or
not
um tom
tell us about your situation hello dude
hello can you hear me yes we can tom
loud and clear
wow
all the way from london
that's amazing uh yeah so basically my
mum my mom's always been pretty open
when it comes to uh
to sexual stuff i guess and then a few
weeks ago she came to me and said
um i found well it was actually my
grandmother that found the receipt
because she was helping to uh tighten
out his room after he went back to
university
but they found the receipt where he
bought an anal probe from um
from
i don't know some website and summers or
something like that and my mum was like
i need i need to ask him because i don't
want him to use it on my bedsheets
and stuff like that so she was like how
do i broach this subject with
with your brother which i found quite
funny seeing as i mean she was quite
happy to tell me about it and i'm
going to use this information quite uh
quite a lot probably in the future but
um yeah just some advice for her to
approach the subject i guess
that's interesting there's a lot kind of
an impact there would would you consider
your mom to be um you know pretty open
when it comes to discussing sexual
matters in general
like do you often talk about sex yeah i
mean
not really i mean like growing up i
remember we were in the car um
uh and she was just like uh i don't i
don't know if you guys have sky over in
america but a cable i guess it's like a
cable provider and they have like adult
channels on there that you can well some
of them are free somebody paid for and
we were in the car i must have been like
i don't know teams um
early teams for mid-teens she's like oh
by the way tom you do realize that
if you want to when we're out you can
you can go on the adult channels uh
you know
you know you can go on them and i was
like why would i do that you know they
cost money and then she was like well
some of them don't and i was like right
okay well i mean i guess that means
what was your reaction to your mom
suggesting that you watched pornographic
content while she was gone
um i don't know i found it pretty well
well i guess quite abnormal but also
quite
nice in some way to be like you know
open about it and not not putting any
pressure and not having to hide
stuff and i mean
yeah you know it was quite nice really i
guess she was quite open i i just think
that she probably was never as open with
my brother so she that's why she was
asking for advice but she probably would
have just made a massive joke of it with
me if you would have found something
from me but you know my brother
do you think maybe your brother is like
jealous of how open your mother is with
you and how she's not as open with him
i've never really considered that i
don't
i don't know
i'm not i'm i'm pretty close to my
brother but not that close so
um what is the age difference between
you and your brother
it's five years so i'm five years older
than him and what you what's your guys's
ages
uh i'm 26 and he's turning 21 uh or he's
22 now maybe actually he's a young man
and he's already found interest in uh
anal pleasure
yeah i think it well i i mean he's got
uh he's got a girlfriend so i don't know
whether or not it's it's for him or for
her but
you know i don't i don't charge that's
for sure and tom have you ever explored
uh anal
uh anally
not not really i'm pretty vanilla if i'm
honest you should ask your brother what
it's like
get his review
well
yeah i mean
well right is there any part of you
where goes like hmm that you know like
his sex life might be a little more
exciting than yours and you're kind of
like
i mean
it's pretty interesting to find the bar
plug and then you're describing your
vanilla sex life right right is there
any uh entry
um
not really i mean i've
i guess yeah i haven't been as
experimental as he might have been but
i've never sort of uh i've never really
been that bothered by it i guess
maybe i am deep down maybe i need to go
and ask to borrow it or something or
find my own i wouldn't i wouldn't borrow
it
yeah i think you should probably get
your own yeah is there anything like
deep down when you really think about it
anything sexually that you've always
wanted to try that
you just haven't because you were too
shy
um
[Music]
we all have our
thing i honestly can't think of anything
off the top of my head
this guy's lying to us
i really can't spit
yeah yeah
um
i mean maybe i'd i me part of me is
thinking that maybe my brother's got the
right idea and maybe i need to
experiment there but
i've never really
that's only just sort of a last-minute
thought rather than anything i've
considered for long-term long-term
if if you get anything out of this make
sure it's that you buy your own and
don't borrow your brothers that's very
important yeah
i think now
back to the original question why on
earth would your mom be concerned
that your brother is going to get anal
juices on her bedding i mean
what are we dealing with here
exactly
i mean so so she lives in quite a small
place so um there's only one other
bedroom so in theory there'll be
multiple guests sharing the bed so i
guess it was just a bit of a like
obviously they'd change the bedding for
out but i just think it's like a
you know maybe maybe just keep it to uh
your own place or back when you're at
uni or something i don't know is it high
quality sheets like what's the thread
count
i don't know i actually i was staying
down there the other day and um and they
were quite bobbly to be fair so these
are kind of crappy
i mean listen the the truth is tom and
this is going to be a bitter
uh pill to swallow for your mom
but the man is going to be having sex in
that bed whether she likes it or not and
which hole is penetrated is kind of
outside of her control
so yeah if she's you know uh if there's
if there's a butt toy involved
you know it's just
it's out of her control i mean you know
just get a good detergent that's my
advice to her
69. um i'll relay that yeah thanks tom
and don't be afraid to tie the try the
butt stuff it's important to
keep your sex life uh
you know
interesting
i'll uh i'll ask my girlfriend when she
gets back from uh when she gets back
from work now cheers guys uh absolutely
love i love you ethan thank you i've
never never seen the gecko before and
this was quite a spectacle so
uh thank you to the therapy guest gecko
as well and
goodbye thank you tom thank you tom
yeah cheers cheers have a good one bye
do you think do you think he was lying
do you think there was a like a thing
that he wasn't telling us that he wanted
to do oh for sure
for sure are you open about that stuff
like would you be willing to
like say what your your thing is
no i wouldn't see see you see he could
have just said that yeah and we would
have been like okay but instead i would
just be honest i wouldn't yeah would you
no yeah exactly yeah but you know it's
rather i'll just acknowledge that yeah
exactly it's better if you acknowledge
it than says i know i know tom has got
some [ __ ] going you know there was
something in his head of course that was
struck by lightning immediately to the
forefront of his brain where he's
getting [ __ ] on his she wants to [ __ ] on
his girlfriend or get [ __ ] on or eat
[ __ ] or i also had a hunch play with
[ __ ] something about his voice outside
100 had something to do with [ __ ] yeah
well tom
best best wishes
um male perspective dealing with
arguments turning 30 this week
what should she anticipate in her 30s
how old are you lyle
how old do you think i am
i think you're below 30 probably i'm 23.
oh you're really young [ __ ]
so you have no perspective no
perspective on this at all
interesting it's lost a lot of
credibility right there
her estranged mother contacted her for
the first time
stopped talking because she hit on
alexa's or her boyfriend
really strange mother
interesting what do you think about that
sounds interesting let's do it
alexa ray alexa
alexa red
can hear you great fantastic
hi thank you for having me
thank you for calling
um so basically uh just to give you a
brief synopsis my mom and i never really
got along
but i haven't spoken to her in about
you know a little over five years
because when i was interested in a guy
i had him over for the first time i was
living with her
and she answered the door to welcome him
in in her bra
are you serious is this real
i'm being a hundred percent dead serious
wow and how did your boyfriend react
um at the time he actually wasn't my
boyfriend he was just a love interest um
my very first i was really head over
heels for him he was my best friend no
are you and i are you intimidated by
your mom's like uh
by her looks is she kind of a uh
a cougar of some kind of sort she
yeah so
she was always like i guess the milf um
the hot mom that everyone wanted to come
over to the house to see i guess
um
so there was always that
but she seemed to do whatever she could
to get attention around my friends and
especially the guys that were interested
in me
um to kind of take attention away from
me
so i don't know if maybe i i don't know
what her issue was but she always we
always bumped heads we never really got
along so um after five years of
you know basically cutting her off i
moved out
and um because i couldn't take the
craziness anymore
um
now she's contacting me again five plus
years later
and i don't really know if i should
speak to her again
what did she say when she reached out to
you
she said that she cared about me she
hopes i'm doing well and
that she would like to talk to me when
i'm ready
um but i don't really know how i feel
about it i mean
i've had a really good place in my life
now and it took me a long time to get
here because i had a pretty rough
childhood that wasn't just it
but that was part of it
so
i feel like maybe i'm healthier without
her in my life but also you know
obviously like when mother's day and
holidays roll around it's like sad to
not have your mom around so
should i give her another chance or what
do you think
i have more questions for you
um
do you feel like your mom was always in
competition with you uh growing up
yeah yeah i i do i feel like she was
definitely
uh she had some i don't know what her
problem was exactly but
she would always like pick out things
that she didn't like about me and say
well if you just fix this about yourself
you would be so much more attractive
you'd be so much prettier guys would
like you or
if you just fixed this about your
personality i think that you would make
more friends and it was always kind of
nitpick
so and what kind of examples would she
pick of that
my hair
she hated that i wouldn't
get highlights in my hair which was
really stupid i know
if i left the house without makeup on
she said that i really should put on
makeup before i leave the house
um
and it was just those little things
and at the time
at the time did you did you like
recognize these things as ridiculous or
did you take them to heart
oh no i i took them super to hard i was
so insecure for a really long time
um
but now i'm i'm pretty
okay with it now
i just it took me a really long time but
that's why i stopped talking to her was
because it wasn't just obviously the guy
that i was really interested in and she
did that and he actually
not to sidetrack or anything but he
ended up coming into my room and we were
talking and he said wow your mom's so
hot
so i was like okay that sucks
so um yeah one one one thing i've
noticed throughout my long 36 years on
earth
not to bash you for your youth
at all
36
is that there are there are sometimes
with mothers who are developmentally
stunted
or had may i assume that she had you at
a young age
um no she actually had me
in her late 20s
so she wasn't super young but she's
always had a problem with i guess
attention
going out and partying and trying to get
guys attention
one thing i've noticed in mother
daughter relationship is that when the
mom competes with the daughter
it can it can be one of the most
damaging dynamics
for
the daughter the daughter should be
having unconditional love and support
and uh character building and
affirmation from the mom when the mom
who's just supposed to be your
support beam
your
your
load-bearing
beam
is the one that within that is that is
uh criticizing and tearing you down for
her own benefit
um that that can be one of the most
damaging
things that can be happened in a young
girl's life
and so i'm first of all very very sorry
uh that you grew up with
with a mother like that as nobody
deserves that
um
how do you feel do you
forgive me if this is insensitive do you
find do you think your mother is more
attractive than you are
um i used to
uh
but i've kind of come into my own i was
really insecure so i thought that
everyone was more attracted than me i
had a really bad time with my self-image
but now that i'm older i take a lot of
pride in how i look and i think
that she might she might have been
jealous when i was
like all of younger
i have my own insecurities but
alexa i just want to say i'm i'm really
proud of you for for your growth i mean
that
that's hard that's a hard thing but
there's basically two outcomes from that
situation yeah yeah what you've achieved
or uh killing men
well there is another thing where like
you know i'm happy because a lot of
times if people like get the kind of
thing that you're getting they'll like
bring it down like if you i i don't know
if you're planning on having kids but it
doesn't sound like if you have a
daughter you're going to do the same
thing to her because a lot of people
feel like we'll do that to like get back
cycles of them yeah cycle and by by you
know
really you know get it getting over and
working on your insecurity you're you're
breaking the cycle and i'm not right
that's everything
thanks guys we still haven't answered
the question because i still have more
questions for you actually is your
father in the picture
yeah he's um we didn't really have a
relationship for
about like seven years of my life but
now we're best friends i mean i
i love him he's amazing and so what was
the reason he wasn't in your life until
recently when you guys became best
friends
um he actually moved to a different
state for work
he had to support us because when the
market crashed he lost his job and
the only thing that he thought he could
do was move back to where he originated
his work from
um because he had a clientele up there
so
he would only be able to really make
money for us if he moved that's what his
you know logic was at the time
but he didn't you guys never talked on
the phone
i had a lot of resentment
towards him for that
so i
i didn't really speak to him and then my
mom had a lot of like
brainwashing tactics i guess like
she would tell us that he abandoned us
and that
you know the lights would turn off and
he didn't pay her and all this stuff
and um really i found out like he was
paying her and he was trying to get in
contact with me so a lot of like
brainwashing i guess
sorry to be so heavy i know this is
supposed to be like
it's not supposed to be anything exactly
it's not supposed to be anything yeah
well but yeah that's why
i think i'm ready to give a final
verdict what are your thoughts on the
mother situation
i mean i you know it sounds like you've
worked very very hard to get to where
you are and um
[Music]
i don't know i wouldn't screw with that
by bringing her back in yeah you
wouldn't risk it no
yeah
so
i have a i would say
i would say be very careful
with this woman
she
um but the mother relationship is so
important
that you know as long as you're cutting
her out like you mentioned on the
holidays and stuff i mean everybody
needs their mom
but you need to keep her at arm's length
you are your own woman
you have built yourself out
you are have a new foundation that is
strong and powerful and you cannot let
her near that foundation
you know i it sounds to me lo that that
that foundation is strong enough to a
point where like if your mom did start
saying stuff to you you'd be like my
foundation's strong enough
she she can't break me anymore right you
know so yeah
do you do you ever
do when your mom would give you any of
these kinds of uh
uh
insults would you ever push back on it
or do you just take it
um when i was younger i would just take
it really
and absorb it
i started pushing back when i was like
around 15 16 and that's when our
relationship got
super tumultuous and bad
um and then i eventually i left when i
was 17. oh wow that was but most of the
time i would absorb it
and if if you started a relationship
with her again and she gave you some of
these comments how do you think you'd
react now
um i think i'd be pretty okay um
obviously it would hurt and it would
just kind of bring up some old
stuff that i think i've already worked
through
so i don't know how i feel about it
i don't know how i'm leaving right now
well you owe her nothing
remember that
and
do whatever is best for you
if you think bringing her in back at a
distance is good if you think you need
more time
you owe her nothing and this choice is
about you
[Music]
amen okay thanks guys i appreciate the
advice
all right alexa thank you so much for
having the the courage to share with us
thank you bye
all right take care good luck out there
you're i've been peeking over at the
chat chat's been very supportive yeah
they liked her yeah
you know
that that is i've seen that time and
again the mom who's jealous of the
daughter and it's just it's such a bad
situation
it's like get over it you're an lady now
you got a child that you need to
support it's not about you anymore you
old hag
that was a great point like the mother's
supposed to be this barrier of like you
know support and it's when it she is the
the bad thing yeah
and you know the thing is
that usually a woman like that obviously
has a as you touched on the cycle right
yeah she probably had a similar mother
and um
she was not able to break the cycle
so i'm proud of alexa for doing it
she did it
alexa ray i was i don't know if she's
one of those people who you have to say
the whole
thing alexa ray alexa ray or lex was
just fine
um
need a relationship advice from a male
perspective about dealing with arguments
need advice for a first date
difficult manager driver calling in i
kind of want to hear about this truck
driver trey the truck driver
trey the truck driver from virginia
what's going on
hey i got a date with this girl that
i've been talking to for like two weeks
and
i we gotta we got first date coming up
tomorrow and i just need some advice i'm
a bit nervous
is this first date different than other
first dates you've had
um
like i don't really go on a lot of dates
because i'm a truck driver and like
dating is hard but
i i feel like there's something special
and it's just like i i'm just getting on
my like super nervous and excited but
i'm just like i don't know
what to say or what to do when i first
see her and i'm just
what was the last day when was the last
date you were on trey
i mean like uh the last date i was on
was with my ex-fiance like three years
ago oh wow
so yeah how long did you like
start trying to go out and and date
again after you broke up with your
fiancee
um well i went through like a period i
became like an alcoholic for like six
months and then like after that i
did like a year of contemplation so like
i don't know maybe like in the past like
years tried to start dating
and once i got my crap together
trey how old are you
uh 26.
gainfully employed pretty good that's
not easy these days it must be really
hard to to date as a truck driver you
are you like how many hours a day are
you on the road
so i'm usually
on the road
consistently for a month and then i get
like a week ahead wow
yeah
trey how would you rate yourself on a
date ability scale of scale to one to
ten how how how uh
how much of a
mate like a as a mate would you rate
yourself
well
i'm i like i like to think that i'm
pretty confident so i'd probably give
myself like a six you know like not
nothing too crazy but nothing too bad
you know doesn't sound that good
of course is there truck dating websites
there is yeah there's gotta be
truckermeet.com or something like that
where did where did you meet your date
is it on a dating app
yeah on a dating app i was passing
through virginia i actually don't live
in virginia i
just i drive everywhere um but i met her
on a dating app and we just started
talking and i saw a profile and i was
just immediately hooked
um
you gave yourself a six what's holding
you back from a higher score
um
i guess it's more just like you know i'm
a bigger guy you know
i'm a truck driver how much do you weigh
so like i feel like that's pretty
i want to say like
285 and how tall are you this time
around that we're leveling up
i'm like 6'4
big guy
yeah
big guy
little heavy are you conscious about
your your your weight uh are you is
losing weight something that you'd like
to do
it's something that i want to do but
like i'm not really too conscious about
it like i'm i'm a bigger guy and i feel
like someone's gonna like me regardless
of whether i'm big or skinny and i i
like to think that i have a pretty solid
personality so i feel like that makes up
for
that potentially what do you think are
the best aspects of your personality
um
i like to think i'm optimistic i like to
i'm usually very happy of course i
suffer from problems like most people
but
i try not to put that too far in the way
of life as it is
you're very tall i mean that's kind of a
lot of girls like that tall [ __ ] it's
big it's big yeah so that that puts you
in you have a job
you're tall
you've got a great personality um i
think you've got a lot going for you
um
so tell me about this girl what's so
special about her
um just like
the way that she is like she's extremely
intelligent like very intelligent she
has like ambition for the future
like when we talk we don't talk like
i i need to sit like a lot of people get
like sexual when they talk with people
but it's like not like that at all like
it's always very like just an
intellectual conversation i don't feel
like i'm talking to a brick wall
you know she has she's very well
traveled like i've been to a lot of
eastern european countries and south
american countries and she's been to a
lot of different countries
so it's just like
i don't know like everything about her
is just like amazing in my opinion
that sounds exciting
how how long have you known her for
um we've we've been talking like every
day for like two weeks and i haven't
really seen any downsides yet i feel
like whatever like she's admit like the
way you were talking about her after
only being talk i know what you say
every day but like two weeks it's like
you don't you don't want to build up
such a high expectation off the bat of
this person that you haven't met yet you
know because then i feel like that's
also going to make you feel like oh
she's so amazing i don't you know
you know stack up to her this is the
classic and i hate to use this term but
you're you're talking about putting the
[ __ ] as they say
on the pedestal yeah
yeah
but but you know i would say listen
dates are stressful
you know especially when they're people
you're interested in there's really
nothing to do about that just uh
try to be yourself really
be yourself and and one thing i will i
will tell you
is when you see her
you know first of all don't play it too
cool tell her
tell her
that she looks nice
that she's so that she's uh that you
love talking with her
you know make her feel comfortable and
let her know that you like her
and that you're and that seeing her
physically because i'm she's probably
just as nervous as you are
and so when you're gonna say i'm seeing
you and i like what i'm seeing and and
let her know that that will that will
make everyone comfortable
don't be afraid to compliment her yeah
and don't be afraid to ask her to
compliment you
say hey well i gave you some compliments
and what about me it's your turn it's
your turn make sure that you get some
compliments out of her
just say it's your turn and stare at her
yeah until she responds do not come
uh do you have a big one
i'm sorry
how many inches is your penis
oh
uh
i i guess i'm pretty average like i
don't i don't when's the last time you
like took out a ruler and genuinely
measured two of the inch
oh man
it
sounds like maybe like
14.
just probably growing oh no it was like
probably likely
mine hasn't really you guys hasn't grown
since you're fourteen
not really yeah i mean i
haven't been you're doing pretty well
well i'm married yeah she's stuck i mean
like yeah we've i've i penetrated her
and had a baby twice so actually that
yeah this is what you should do is you
should get uh this girl pregnant and
then she'll be with you forever
that's a strategy that you could use
listen um
listen
just be yourself dates are stressful i'm
happy for you
you know
and um and just get out just get in
there and just show her that trey
trucking ain't the only thing he can do
what do you do to pass the time on the
road trey
uh
it's gonna sound really
like you know unoriginal but i like to
listen to your podcast thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you
do you do drugs or anything when you're
driving to stay up
uh no i i i'm a good trucker i follow
d.o.t law i i i stop when i stop and
yeah i i've never done drugs a damn mile
a lot i've drank alcohol but i never
like smoked weed or anything like that
in my life good boy do you have a lot of
friends that are truckers is there like
a is it like is it like a scene
you know
um
not really like i mean i have like a
couple friends who are truckers people i
went to like trucking school with but
uh most of the friends that i have we
play aren't people i've played d and d
with and like other tabletop games i'm a
huge nerd i'm sorry i feel like d it's
like a lengthy experience it seems like
it's trucking
he's it's kind of a form of trucking at
home right right it's trucking at home
would you would you say that's accurate
trey the truck driver um i've
i
i would say like when it comes down to
like the indy and stuff like that it's
more just like the like i just like to
go into like this world of imagination
you know it's like an escape from
like the monotony of the day-to-day
world like
i usually play at night when i'm done
driving for the day so it's like a
really equal healthy yeah
school what is that like what is
trucking school why how is that real
give it to greg oh man uh for the
company i work for
you apply online and like they'll
bring you there and they'll
hmm
sounds pretty easy
thank you trey
if he dropped
oh no he lost he sounds like a tall guy
you know if you're tall
it's like it makes it it's like a
it's just it's unfair to a short i'm not
i'm not i don't consider myself a short
king but i'm average height
i'm like i'm 511 on a good day okay cool
i'm five i i used to tell people i'm
five six and a half i used to bump it up
and tell people i was five seven i was
like [ __ ] it i'm five six this is who i
am embrace it embrace it exactly don't
even go for that exactly exactly i don't
even go for the half i just embrace
fully look i'm a five six mother do you
consider yourself a short king or like
an average king um i i would say i'm in
i think five six these days is
considered a short guy short king yeah
short k how do you feel about being a
short
man i used to care more than i do but
it's like i can't change it you know
it's one thing if like you know if i
were like self-conscious about my weight
or anything you could change that you
can't
change you can't change the height you
can't change the height yeah change
whatever else you can around that's
exactly right you know you get you can't
change what you can't change exactly
and that guy's got like a whole foot on
me
yeah he said he's 6'4
i want to ask him where the date was the
problem with having an average sized
penis though when you're 6'4 is that
it's going to look small exactly exactly
that's kind of the advantage of being
short yep
it looks always going to look bigger
i've been told i have like a goldilocks
penis
perfect size yeah not too big
not too small i've been told my peni my
penis is like cold porridge oh really
why it was a massive penis it's just
in the goldilocks analogy that was the
one she didn't like oh
too cold
did the person who told you who told you
that not like you're a penis
presumably i haven't
analyzed it too much but that would be
the conclusion yeah
i'm glad that you haven't thought about
it like it hasn't kept you it's too
painful
goldilocks goldilocks good for you thank
you
okay
well you have that going
yeah
for
you
whatever i can build
okay
let's see what else we got
uh how to get through this covid
shifting to real world but not a lot of
people are vaccinated
hmm
uh about to get married want some advice
on how to keep a marriage fresh and make
it last
that's all you
want advice for applying to jobs what do
you think about that yeah let's hear
that's here jack
jack i want to help you find a job
hello uh hi i'm a big fan
thank you jack so
yeah so basically um you know i've been
uh
i've been looking for jobs in this
i don't want to say post coded world but
you know we're kind of coming out of it
a little bit
and you know a lot more things are
opened up than they were a year ago
and
it's been surprisingly hard for me to
find a job
um
i did apply
to a topgolf
um
it's exciting which is
yeah it's basically like a golf but uh
it's like bowling i guess i don't know
we know what top golf is but anyway
actually i don't know what to do okay
it's a driving range they said it has
bowling too yeah no
that was just an analogy oh okay
it's just it's a it's like a it's like a
new age golfing uh
a driving range oh okay very popular uh
with the kids oh it's cool do they like
serve beer there yeah i think so okay
that sounds cool and they can like track
how far your drive goes and stuff like
screens and computers and [ __ ]
i don't really know
i've never been to one what is topgolf
uh jack
um yeah so you basically got it like you
just it's like a driving range but it's
like three or four stories
and um
they track your balls somehow
anyway i don't know don't ever apply
there that's just gonna be my
two cents because i had the worst job
application process of all time
um
basically uh they had what's called a
hiring event
i don't know if you've ever
witnessed or experienced one of these
but basically
um
is the whole ordeal it was like a three
hour thing
um
it was
one of these um
like group things where you had to share
a fact with the group
and you haven't been hired yet
i have not well they'll call me back and
just they're making you come share with
the group but you haven't been you
haven't been offered anything what fact
did you share with the group
great question um
r so i told them that i play guitar so
that was like my little corny
you know did you did you think that was
a good fact to share in retrospect
um
i don't think it was bad but i think you
know there could have been a
fact maybe that was a little more useful
of all the facts that people shared what
did you find what fact did you find the
most interesting
that made you feel bad about your fact
well i don't know if this one was
necessarily uh great for hiring but like
there was this one woman who
i think she was around like 60 and she
said she was a retired
uh pe teacher and she said that she's
had to listen to so much kids bob
that she could go crazy
but did that get a laugh
yeah i got a laugh i got a chuckle did
that make you kind of feel like damn i i
wish i got a laugh yeah yeah
yeah i was like one of the first people
you know and so i didn't really know
what's like the that is tough they call
that under the gun in poker interesting
yeah yeah
yeah
um so you came with a bad fact do you
think that that affected your kind of
your status what you like your your your
potential as a as an employee
um
yeah i think that i think the fact would
be important um
but there was so much other stuff
like when they actually eventually took
us to interview
um
i kind of uh i made a mistake um with
what like positions
i wanted to apply for because they just
um they got the wrong ones
and um i didn't want to correct them and
be you know like that guy
everything
so what did you so tell me about what
position you you applied for
on accident like break that down for us
so basically i wanted to be just kind of
like a waiter you know or like um
you know like a buster something like
that
and you think you think sharing a better
fact would have affected your
year yeah i definitely yeah i think yeah
definitely a better fact if you could
turn back time
and give a new fact what was your new
family i would say like i like to put
the dishes away
fantastic fast yeah
i like to
serve
white women mimosas you know is there no
is there no uh
there's no other racial or there's no
other members of any other race to
attend that uh
that top golf um
i i wouldn't know because i've never you
never worked there right
did you at least like were you a patron
before did you
scope out the top golf before to see if
it was a good place they're not open
they're like it's it's opening
this august and um i've been to one in
like arizona before but
obviously i haven't been to this one
jack if you could if you could do
literally anything
like a dream job what would that be
dream job
um you know i want to be a stand-up
comedian
um i it's something like in doing
entertainment
for a child exactly
do do you have do you have any jokes do
you have material
um
yeah i mean
yeah mostly like stories stuff like that
you know what's your best are you are
you are you prepared to deliver a story
to us now live
um yeah i said if you want
absolutely
but just take your time here's the
here's what i'm gonna promise you jack
i promise to be on brutally honest with
you okay
and that's what you should want from
your audience if you want to improve
absolutely so
jack i just want to prepare you that
before you get into this be prepared
that we are going to be brutally honest
with you
how how long is this story
good question um it's always good to ask
let me you know i think uh
just to keep it kind of on topic i'll do
the story of my
my appliance to topgolf well that's what
it's about but oh we already heard that
story
yeah yeah you heard the abridged version
this is the uh this is the [ __ ] of the
experience this is the bit okay yeah so
this is the bed
okay so this is this is let me how much
work is this a bit that you are kind of
that you've prepared
this is a bit that we said okay this is
the bit i've rehearsed this i know the
beats i know the laughs or is this just
going in kind of dry
i performed it a few times okay okay
it's been four and four great okay
jack
the mic is yours
we are your captive audience
okay
um
all right
so uh i uh i've been looking for a job
for a while and uh i applied to topgolf
um i don't know if you've ever heard of
that
um but basically
what it is is it's a four-story driving
range
and i had a
client's
experience that
almost shook my world
it
shook
my belief in humanity
um
and uh
it was just
i i i don't know it was a scarring
experience
basically i got a text saying that they
were doing a hiring event
um i don't know what a hiring event is
um
i just assume that i go there and apply
but you know whatever
so i go there do you know
do you think so a joke should have
occurred but not not to criticize but
like are we getting the setup or the i
feel like they're you need the you need
to punch up some of these beats of the
story definitely i think i think i think
if there's nothing funny going on yet we
need a cut to the chase situation right
where it's like i went to a i went to a
hiring event at topgolf yes the set the
stage is set already right right like
i'm done
i'm hearing too many like thought like
you're giving your thoughts about every
beat of the thing i just want to hear
the beat which would be funny which
would be fine if you had jokes about
that right right but so far
what we're getting at is
we're doing we're doing the employment
event at topgolf do you want to start
over or do you want to continue
yeah i'll start over okay okay
are you starting from the very beginning
yeah with our notes please
yeah with your notes okay let's see if
you incorporate them
all right so i went to a hiring event at
topgolf the other day it was very short
um
uh one thing about this event that was
different than most is the pitbull and
katy perry music that was bland in the
background it was very jarring and um
just kind of like that whole
group
attitude of you know we are we're the
best
uh we're the best
that kind of stuff and um
so we all get together and they start
with a little q a you know
and um
basically uh
they say uh
you know if you have any questions we'll
answer them and it's dead silence nobody
says anything and i'm thinking like okay
we'll just be able to skip the q a
portion
but uh this one woman
decides to ask you know she goes what
are five things you like about working
at topgolf and i'm like you know why the
[ __ ] do you need five things you know
why do you need like two things at most
i think two things is
you know that's good but
what if you need five reasons to work
somewhere then just don't [ __ ] work
here
um
when you talk you know
you you told you told this at like an
open mic or a comedy club right that's
what you said
a few times a few times okay and how did
it how did it
go when you did
um
well the setup yeah obviously it was
just people you know just kind of
listening and then when i started
getting into the
um
jokes the funny part have we entered
that part yet i'm uncertain if we have
no no offense i just have we entered the
joke portion of this can we get cut
straight to the point where you felt
like with people in the audience were
responding yeah well yes
yeah and then probably my advice would
be to get to that part as soon as
possible cut everything before that part
pretty much
okay
so the event was hosted by a man named
wolverine i [ __ ] you not his name was
actually wolverine
um and when they introduced him they
sort of just got in a circle
and um did a
you know welcome wolverine and they got
out of banner for him to run through and
as soon as he hits that banner he eats
[ __ ] so hard
he falls to his [ __ ] face all right
and tries to play off like you know
nothing happened
and um
this is the funny part
um it's supposed to be this is the mark
well jack i mean you're really just
recounting what happened i think if you
want to be a stand-up comedian you're
going to have to
add something to
the story that is uh
or an original edition of your own
that's funny i mean this the the the
anecdote of somebody falling is um
i would i would uh hesitate to call that
a bit
i mean do you have a certain like you
you have to have some sort of commentary
on the fall was there anything you
noticed about the fall a simile it was
like when this happened with this thing
you know
do you have any further commentary on
the fall that might be humorous
the fall
it was uh
it was the fall
um much similar
it was the fall of a man
50 year old man
who goes by the name
yeah was he okay i'm actually worried
that he's 50.
did he resemble wolverine at all in a
physical appearance
no he did it oh no he did not look
jackman so maybe that well not hugh
jackman i resent that
wolverine
is a fictional character that existed
long before hugh jackman so let's not
even go there okay uh jack
okay thank you i i i'm very sorry
he looked like gerard
you know
okay he uh you know he kind of looked
like
so maybe what's funny is that his name
was wolverine but he didn't look like
wolverine right
was it was he writing in pain for a
while afterwards
of the uh like the school master from
matilda you know
no i haven't seen matilda i have it's
been a while though it's a very specific
reference
i mean again well it's very specific
reference maybe that'll resonate with
one person and uh
jack i think you have a long way to go
i'm not saying give up but i am saying
that um
get it keep going you know keep getting
out there and getting the experience
and um
and uh you know never say never right
i know it it's hard to
stand up in front of
one of your idols
oh thank you now you're talking about me
yeah yeah thank you jack i appreciate
that i'm not going to tell you give up
but you know just keep working on you're
probably a young guy right like how old
are you
i'm 18. yeah you're a young guy just
keep slamming all right jack
keep slamming those balls
all right take care buddy take care
he will not warm up
[Music]
you know uh
he seemed like a sweet guy maybe he'll
make it i hope you know he gets in
somewhere at some job i hope someone
pays him
i believe somewhere out there there is
an entity an organization a single
person that will pay jack
to perform
a task
in exchange
for money
he'll make it in that regard i believe
he'll make it in that report but you
know apparently there's like a big
employment shortage right now yeah yeah
so but he's 18. so the world is so hard
and so scared 18. i'm not even going to
front like when i was 18 doing anything
was was hard doing jokes looking for a
job i mean come on and you know jack
just keep going man just keep slamming
don't be like jack from titanic he sunk
he did
you're gonna swim do you have any advice
from i'm a little bit younger than you
do you have any advice for me is growing
do you have a specific kind of question
not really
just advice just advice
anything you wish that you would have
known when you were my age
hmm
well to be honest with you i think
you're doing great i mean you've got
this whole gecko thing
which has got to be exciting it is when
i was your age i dreamed of doing comedy
but it wasn't until i was about um
[Music]
25 26 until i started pursuing that
passion
so you're ahead of the game what were
you doing when you were 23. i was just
doing a desk job i was doing marketing
some kind of bull crap
so i'm afraid that one day you know i'll
have to i'll because i used to do like
marketing stuff
i'm afraid one day i'll have to go back
and do that
yeah that's the i had that fear for a
long time too yeah but let it motivate
you okay i will let it push you yes
every day yes
to say i am never i am not going back
[Music]
i will never go back i'll never go back
what do you what are weak point where
are points soft spot spots in your life
that you're like this is something i
want to see myself doing better at
ah man
i don't know i want to get better at
uh talking to strangers on the phone in
a gecko costume okay that's i guess
that's the main thing that i do so i
should always be striving to
get better at that perfect that art the
fact that i right um
you know i want to get better at talking
to people in person too
i wonder if you could take some kind of
if if that's your singular goal sure
you might want to take some kind of like
uh therapy therapy therapist classes and
you know people have always asked me
like you should people said like you
should like actually go to school and
become a real therapist i never want to
do that no you don't have to you don't
have to commit but like you could read a
book pick up a book about like the
basics of psychoanalysis or therapy
you could probably pick up a lot of
useful
theories yeah i could probably
learn
as much just reading like one so really
good book
than like going to i fully believe that
okay yeah fully believe that did you go
to college yeah would you study creative
writing
do you feel like no yeah
no
college is you can no you read one good
book you can read an internet article
and the thing is like you know college
textbooks are are written in the so that
you don't learn anything really
i think so
i think they're written in that way
where if you get like a stupid or like a
good like 4.5 star book from amazon
forget about it
also i feel like you know when they when
i get like a signed reading in school
i'd be like oh great i don't have to do
anything and as opposed to like when i
actually have an active interest in a
book i'll i'll sit exactly you care
about it yeah
yeah we just focus on that but i think
you're good i don't you know i don't
think that uh
i don't i don't think you have much to
worry about just keep doing your thing
you know thank you ethan
you're very welcome
yeah
are you worried about like dating are
you worried about the money how's your
money situation i'm doing i'm doing okay
i'm uh you know i mean you know how it
is with like twitch it's very variable
yeah i mean you know you're probably
doing
are you making more than you were at
you're
marketing job yeah yeah i'm making like
about not by i mean i'm making like
about as much
a little bit a little bit more yeah
i see
but it could all but i think the
advantage of like the job of course is
that it's a guaranteed
every you know that you get your money
whereas yeah that's the only advantage
yeah that's the only advantage but i
think someday soon you'll be surpassing
that thank you for believing i do
believe in you absolutely
when do williams
[Music]
is that wendy williams voice yeah
you want to talk to more people how long
we've been going dan
uh
a little over an hour i think
what that's impossible we've been going
longer than that
oh well i must be wrong then
got him let's do it proved him wrong
we're running out of money by the way on
the call in studio oh yeah how much
money is it it auto uh refills oh it
doesn't by the way i'm looking at this
thing right now i don't know if i've
told you before i use google voice yeah
it's the most biggest [ __ ] of
like does this look good to you i'm
switching to call in studio where you
can like read everyone that's amazing so
here let's i'll pitch some deal advice
on a friend who wants to borrow money
ooh
that's pretty juicy i like that
you wanna do that one sure let's see
that one amber from wisconsin
25 years old
amber we're here to help
we're here to help
amber
amber hello friends can you hear me we
can hear you amber you sound lovely how
can we help you
um i am just looking for some advice on
not even really a friend it's an old
co-worker say no of mine
who
has
been asking
like everyone that has used to work with
us for money now and just if
if this is somebody that you're not even
close with why do you why are you even
concerned right with the thought of
saying no that should be an easy
response from you
because she
used to be close to me back in the day
and the only reason we
are out of touch is because she moved
um
but just like me being the helper that i
am would like to try and offer at least
advice so she doesn't burn bridges with
more people because it's kind of getting
out of hand as having her ask her you
will not um you will not change their
situation
okay you will not change their situation
that's good to hear amber would you say
that on the whole you consider yourself
in general to be a people pleaser
i try to be as best as i can
does that ever cause you
stress and uh anxiety
oh yeah
oh yes
do you feel that maybe someone could
help you that's about time someone you
know help you out
yes i feel like i definitely need to
learn how to
redistribute my
priorities but like someone just coming
and like it feels like a very like
personal one-on-one like request from
her that's why it was hard for me to
just say no
right away
but
it's yeah it's definitely something i
need to work on too it's just being okay
like letting people down
but you know it's not a personal request
because you know this person is asking
other acquaintances
yes you're right
why is this person asking people for
money
um i don't
i know there is some like
drama because of
her and her new husband did both lose
their jobs last year and are forced to
like move actually back with his parents
but i know also like they have had some
substance abuse problems as well so
there's a lot of different
avenues where this money could be going
to that's why i think me and a lot of
my friends are also
saying no because it's
we don't know where it's actually going
and she's been asking for even like 20
bucks and we're like why this is even
like worth the embarrassment of asking
like that's bad that's a that's a
their their my my assumption would be
that
it's dr it's for drugs
and you know usually that is very
embarrassing to ask for twenty dollars
because it's like
and especially someone that you're not
even acquainted with i mean it sounds
like they're pretty close uh
to
they're they're they're they're in deep
and uh
that's a tough situation obviously and i
would uh you giving them money is not
going to uh
that's a tough one i mean obvi it's a no
for me though for sure you're okay so
you're having trouble like
mustering the you know whatever it is to
say no because that makes you feel
bad right
well i just don't like i have no issues
saying no like i'm not made of money
either but it's more just like i wish i
could be
like go a step further and like
offer
advice or like right yeah i think
she doesn't want your advice
right she wants your mommy
yeah and the problem is uh that um
[Music]
i i haven't really dealt with someone
who's deep into addiction in that way
but like you know i wouldn't i wouldn't
necessarily even think that that was
your your cross to bear i mean she's an
acquaintance
and that that's a difficult situation
because once you start giving them money
they're going to think you're the piggy
bank
you can't take on everyone i know that
you want to and i really genuinely
respect the fact that you're a caring
person but you can't take on everyone's
stuff
and this is far right this isn't even
like really close yeah exactly this is
like a problem that like a tumbleweed
that just uh
blew across your your front door i mean
this isn't even really something
something that uh
you need to even really think about
taking on
right
yeah i just needed the reassurance that
i'm not
a shitty person for just being like no
and also like please never contact me
again but
i just want to be as
helpful as i can because i have no idea
of really what she's going through but
i feel like people on top are like
they're afraid to set boundaries because
they're afraid of being seen as a city
shitty person but that's what you're
doing is you're setting you know healthy
boundaries for yourself which doesn't
make you a shitty person
all right
well i appreciate it guys
yeah do you do you feel like people kind
of walk all over you is that something
that you deal with in your life do you
feel like maybe people take advantage of
you
um kind of i'm like reading in chat like
it's just the midwest personality and it
definitely is that like
i think people know that i'm
50
or like way more caring than not caring
so
yeah i definitely feel like there is
some walking over me happening
um
do you feel like that's something that
you want to address within your
personality to make yourself less easily
to walk over are you happy with with who
you are in that regard
um i feel like i'm
happy
just being someone like that people can
at least reach out to
like for advice but like i feel like
just even
being like in college i feel like money
was such an issue with like roommates
and stuff like that that
i never want to get involved in
something like that again just because i
feel like it earned so many bridges
yeah what happened in college
oh just
i feel like every
house situation like
if i had like utilities or whatever in
my name it'd be like i'd move out and
then i wouldn't get paid and then they'd
make me seem like the bad person for
wanting the money that they owe me but
yeah just more of the like being a
pushover what you've already picked up
on
yeah we just politely say uh listen
it's not me babe
all right
but uh we wish you well
thank you for sharing him lots of
prosperity
and um
and uh
thank you for calling
all right thank you so much guys okay
take care bye amber andrew
oh we have a recommendation from the
screeners oh what do they say there's
one about the
let me see here
uh this one sounds really interesting
genetically passed down fetishes
hello dina let's do it dina what is a
genetically
inherited fetish
we can hear you loud and clear hit us
awesome so yeah i wanted to like kind of
talk about that because growing up i
grew up with a single dad
and um i had to go on his laptop
sometimes to print things out and i
would see like his porn history
and um how old were you it makes me
uncomfortable because i was
the first time i saw probably like
six or seven oh my goodness
and did you know what you were saying at
the time did you understand
i would say yes i kind of grew up um
kind of sexualized at a very early age
so
yeah i was kind i kind of knew what i
was looking at and it makes me
uncomfortable because i have like this
very similar fetishes to him and i hate
that
okay well let
let's start from the top what did you
see on your dad's computer
spanking porn and bondage porn
specifically okay
how old were you
when you sort of started to realize that
you like
that stuff
how old are you
i'm 20. okay thank you
uh when i started to know that i was
into that so probably 12. i like i said
i grew up very sexual at an early age
i don't know how to do this
this is this is above my pay grade
uh but here's what here i have a
solution when this happens you do i do
dina have you ever spoken to a real
therapist
not two guys not two years been going to
therapy for years okay okay what is what
does your real therapist have to say
about this
good call
um that i shouldn't have seen that
okay and it definitely caused some
damage that's kind of what what they
said
my advice continue to see your real
therapist
continue to pay attention
and to their counsel
and i'm proud of you for
going to seek out help with this issue
from a legitimate source
and yeah i see in the chat people are
saying has he ever thanked you no no no
no didn't ask
didn't ask that didn't ask that neither
of us ask that question i want to be
clear
nor did i want to know that no
no no no no
i'm not qualified um
dina thank you so much for calling and
um
[Music]
uh continue to see your real therapist
for any further information about this
ah
of course no i don't want advice more
just your take on it like if you think
that that's true that it's genetically
passed down
you know again i i don't know because
there's probably a lot of environmental
factors at play i mean clearly your
father whatever he's into or people
close around you uh rub off on you some
way possibly subconsciously so like are
we talking about like to do to conduct a
real study on that you would need to
be raised separate from your father and
then say this girl likes to be spanked
we know her dad likes to be spanked
they've never met yeah that would be
proof but the fact but you know your dad
might have big ping-pong paddles around
the house or like
too many variables yeah for there to be
a controlled there would have to be a
more controlled experiment yeah
you know
so i i obviously um we're going to have
to get a geneticist in here to to
give you an answer on that but uh
but uh
thank you uh dina it's a hell of a
question all right take care good luck
with that goodbye dina bye dina thanks
for calling sorry we couldn't answer
more it's just
uh
it's we can't no i appreciate it thank
you
you know that happens all that happens
all the time on my stream like if i'll
get someone yeah you handled that good
and that's what i that's why i always
i'm just like have you talked to a real
therapist and then if they say yes i'm
like what did they say and if they say
no it's like
maybe you should you should do that but
i mean it's in terms of all the fetishes
i mean spanking certainly isn't the
worst i mean it seems relatively
harmless but when you get into bondage
then [ __ ] can get pretty weird i think
she's just weird regardless of like what
the fetish is i think she's just weirded
out by the fact that she has the same
one she shares with her dad whatever it
would be just the fact that she shares
it is her problem i think
this is why i could never be a real
therapist like what is i i always wonder
like in like the universe like when you
go to study psychology
do like do you come out
feeling adequately prepared to answer
questions like that like what are they
what are they training you to do i think
so because it's more about like feelings
it's like how do you feel it's not about
like oh is this because it's about like
how do you feel
why do you feel that way
let's just explore that feeling
so you know it always very very much
just comes down to
understanding
why they feel the way they do yeah yeah
so it could be any situation
fascinating stuff fascinating stuff
um
i need some words of affirmation about
asking out the girl of my dreams need a
compliment boost i think we already kind
of okay yeah
yeah we sort of got that with the
trucker guy difficult manager
give it to the man let's give it to the
man
isabella from portland
let's give it to the man what's tell me
about this manager and uh and let's
let's try to stick it to him if we can
isabella
it's a little bit of a doozy though
okay we're here for disney
okay
first of all are we talking about sexual
doozies
no no okay just making sure
when you say doozy i don't know what you
mean by that
i know we're you know we're talking
about ryan kavanagh a lot and he does
resemble harvey weinstein he does that's
a good observation
but ryan cavanaugh the guy who's suing
me he looks just like harvard is that a
big like you don't know about that no
it's not a meme i genuinely just think
he looks like harvey weinstein
yeah he looked about it
yeah
everyone's staying
right now
isabel you're breaking up a little bit
but go ahead what is the problem with
your manager let's deal with this
all right so my dad owns this company
right and now there's
there's three owners they all have you
know equal shares or whatever so we've
got it it's medicinal cannabis if you
will blaze 420.
you know you know the butt well actually
i don't think you really don't smile but
every day
so i'm growing the weed i'm a gardener
you know all of that so
it's pretty fun but then it comes down
to the fact you know what's this amber
or sorry isabelle do you know what this
is
what is this that's a green thumb oh
[ __ ]
we need a dj air horn on that one
zach
dj air horn nothing
all right
now you're asking me for somebody yeah
she is hit her i think it's a reasonable
request yeah exactly where's the air
horn at i
i think it's reasonable i'm surprised
that's not already mapped to a button
zach she caught you slacking a little
bit
[Applause]
[Music]
that was good go ahead isabella all
right
so my manager knows nothing about
growing weed i don't think he's ever
done it a day in his life correctly i'm
not really sure where they found this
guy
my dad's never there
um so the other boss one of the other
owners he's there and i guess mother
nature must have died one day and told
him that he is it and he knows
everything that he possibly needs to
know about the plants
but he's killing them and at this point
he doesn't trust anybody else to take
care of
so i'm a manager of a room i've got two
big rooms full of plants
two big flower rooms two big bedrooms
and
he won't even let me
water them anymore because he thinks
that he can do it better than any of the
people who have actually been laboring
for the past i've been there for about a
year now but there are other people who
have been there longer than i have
shouldn't there be kind of like a
brewmaster like you know how like there
needs to be like some person who's in
charge of the gardening i mean that
seems like an important job when you're
when you're growing a cash crop
exactly and that's where
that's where my my manager we can call
him
we'll call him brian
he
doesn't have i don't he's supposed to be
it's called the head grower the master
grower just like you said so he's got
the and he
well does does he not have
go ahead i'm sorry
he makes for any bonus that i get
technically any good grower knows you're
supposed to get about two
pounds per light two pounds per plant
that's average
so if i get any bonuses for all the hard
work that i do
um i'm in there every day i actually am
the only one that cuts the plants and
propagates the roots for cloning and
then
grows them
from start to finish i'm the only one at
the facility who can do that and he gets
about
i don't even know how much money he gets
but if we get a bonus number so like our
good numbers for our room harvest
he gets like thousands to where i get
about 25 of it when he doesn't do
anything he just walks around all day
just doing nothing like he just pretends
like he's working and
nobody clocks him on that
you know isabella
have you ever considered if you have the
skills to to grow on your own start in
your i don't know what the [ __ ] is
involved with permits or whatever but
you ever considered starting your own
little little business
that's the best way to stick it yeah so
i am i'm really interested in doing that
because
i don't know like i get treated so
poorly there like i just recently went
away for a few days and i didn't even
take vacation time i just made up my
time the weekend before leaving
and i still get treated as if i slack
off and or whatever which i don't
i i think that like i'm trying to get my
dad because he handles more of the sales
side of things i'm trying to get my dad
to
really see the light but the premise of
this the the premise of this is a little
confusing your dad is the owner
so so so if your dad is the owner and
this guy is just a manager
uh you should have no problem taking
this up the totem pole right
so there's this manager brian
he's the douche that we don't like
yeah
yeah and then
there's this guy we'll call him ryan
because we already hate ryan's out here
zach
zach is he's he's bitter about your
earlier uh jest at
him well i'm still bitter at craft mayo
for not picking him as the mayo man oh
she's on my side all right just one zack
over big time yeah
thank you very much
zach entered a male contest
believer of the curse but i am i shut
that [ __ ] down if i hear any of the
claims climbing you know all that climax
cline water wow i actually like this
person thank you thank you for calling
in
a while and i
why what does your dad say when you say
hey
you know we've got this master grower he
doesn't know what he's doing the plants
are dying shouldn't that be apparent to
everybody why is it that nobody sees
what you see right
so everybody all the other employees do
and they're all just as frustrated but
the thing is is in this day and age you
need to have a lot more of a reason to
fire somebody
rather than they just aren't
super good at their job i guess i'm
pretty sure that is a good reason to
fire someone
i
i agree but i guess if it's not like
malicious intent or anything
then it's a lot more difficult my
problem is that um
ryan the other guy he is an owner as
well so he's not he doesn't know
anything about plants he owns other
businesses he just owns businesses you
see like your dad's
friend or something
they i don't really know how they knew
each other but now it's kind of so it's
my dad handles the sales
um this guy handles the operations at
the grow and then the other owner
handles like the trimming and the
production of that
so it's
where where my
[ __ ] end of the stick falls is that the
guy
who's the other owner i can't
he he's so disrespectful i'll be scared
i will all be standing there having a
conversation and i'll say
i'll put my two cents in and they'll
look at me
and then they will look at each other
and they will just continue to talk as
if i didn't say anything or i wouldn't
they don't respect you they don't
respect your input
but my plants are always the best and i
have my own plants at home
that are outside right now because it's
the season for it and they're doing
really well and so i don't really
i always say that and they try to tell
me that i can't compare it because it's
outdoor compared to indoor growing
that's what i'm saying you should go
into yeah
what do you think about that her
starting her own thing well i don't know
the logistics of it like you said about
like yeah i don't know like you can grow
your own stuff and then drop it off at a
head like a coffee shop whatever i don't
know yeah i don't know but one thing i
do know is that um
i'm assuming there's other places to
work right where people might might
respect your your growing capabilities
more or maybe maybe it's time
how do you get those credentials of
being the master grower because that
sounds like something you'd be good at
how do we get you these credentials so
that you can actually come in and say i
am isabella the [ __ ] master grower
and you will bow to me
there is the air horn moment
[Music]
i'm with you because that's i've been on
indeed a lot lately um last week
specifically because i i was caring
about it so much because it's not just a
paycheck for me at this particular place
is my dad
does your dad
does your dad know that you're looking
uh for other jobs because the situation
has gotten that toxic for you
yeah he does because i finally outlined
it to him because i'll go in there and
like i'm not
super tough like i'm pretty sensitive to
things but i try not to get really
emotional especially in the workplace
i've had management roles before i've
you know i trained everybody there that
you know come after me and i try to
present myself
you know professional um even whatever
i'm doing and i've just come in and just
gotten absolutely beaten down because i
was putting my heart and my soul in it
and i wasn't eating i was hardly
sleeping i was living off of
like i was just taking my medication and
drinking red bulls every day and that
was it so i told him i'm like i i i love
working in this this is something i want
to do
um but i just can't no amount of money
would be worth
my compromising my
integrity so i did what you were guys
were kind of talking about earlier and i
am renting a
botany textbook um an introduction to
plant biology from amazon can i ask you
something i can't
of course is it possible that this man's
a better grower than you give him credit
for
[Music]
because
honestly if he was then the plants
probably wouldn't all be dying
but how did he get the job because
clearly he has some credentials right
no so i'm not really sure because the
people who recommended him to be
um
you know work for us when we were in a
pinch before they do not work for us
anymore and they were actually lacked
i heard they were bad melting our
company on facebook because they
wanted to
work from home
in a cannabis industry and that's just
not really how things work in that
industry so
um they don't even work for us anymore
um the thing about him is that he
doesn't even grow he doesn't know how to
water the plants he doesn't know how to
do all these things and that's
the issue so now we are well i want to
talk to you i think i think you've got
some fundamental issues at that place it
seems dysfunctional to me yeah i i i i
i'm like stuck on this but you know have
you looked into what it would take
logistically to
start up some sort of business of your
own
yeah i think the biggest hurdle is um
property right now and money i don't
have the money to just like start up
um what's what is good about it is that
my dad has a lot of people in the
industry so they can
um
they can what well my plants are all
going to be sent out to extracts
my plans that i'm doing out if your dad
knows a lot of people in the industry
could he help you get a different job or
would that be kind of awkward because he
you work for his company
well honestly i i think with the
direction that's going in he doesn't
really want to
be
if
if it's going to be the way that they're
treating everybody there they're not
really going to have much of a company
in
a few months time
that where they once had he was the sole
owner
now they're bringing other people in
they won't they don't they just won't
put any money into it other than
standard products
right but
we're focusing right now on how to make
your life better not on how to make the
company as a whole better
i know i think i just i feel like i feel
bad for them
even though they do treat me
like trash i think that i think that
business is uh
if if they're hiring master growers that
don't know how to grow and nobody's
taking accountability there's three
owners i mean uh some some something's
got to give here
and uh it's not your cross to bear
isabella and uh just be just plant some
trees damn it plant some trees
you know some seeds water them my trees
going in dad's yard and they i don't do
much to them and i cut the clones i cut
them off plants from our facility i
propagated are you high right now
isabella
me no you're not high do you smoke uh
frequently
yeah i do how often do you smoke
um well i start my day off and i take a
dab
a dab that that's pretty serious right a
dab is like pretty hardcore
so did you take a dab today
this morning
i actually just took a dab right before
like a couple people ago but
you're not high anymore i thought the
dabs are like yeah you said you're not
high can you can you unpack that bro
no i don't retract that it's like when
you smoke a lot your tolerance goes up
so
so how many downtimes so how many times
do you smoke in a day would you guess
well
um
probably like five times a day like i'll
smoke on lunch
oh i'm surprised but that's the thing is
when you're functional you can get a lot
of stuff done i feel like we're in a
very narrow window here of you not being
high because it sounds like it sounds
like we caught you at the five minutes
of the day that you're not high if
you're telling the truth
well i'm
i know i'm actually i'm supposed to go
i'm supposed to go over to my friend's
house but um i'm gonna
try to get some advice because this is
like
free therapy right well sure i don't
know if it's it is free but i don't know
if it's therapy maybe
do you think your friend will have good
advice for you
yeah we've been kind of going through it
like for a while trying to figure out
what what we can do but i think you're
right i think it really is just time for
me to kind of just build my resume from
the experience that i've gained working
in visibility how much do you know how
much do you spend on weed
well actually um i don't really have to
spend a lot you get free stuff from the
place right that's what i was thinking i
mean that that that's gonna that's a big
perk it is that's a huge part because
god knows how much you're spent you'd be
spending if you weren't
in that in that industry yeah
you know
well the good news is i mean you're not
wrong the good news is if your boss ever
pisses you off too much you can
blaze
you just get high people say that helps
yeah that's i mean that's true i i try
to do that as much as i can we've got
our we got our break in the morning and
our break in the afternoon and i've got
my friends that work there they're
they've become friends with them
what's the what's the company policy
with taking marijuana
um there really isn't much
a policy for that there's just no
smoking inside i try not to smoke around
my plants i try to i tell other people
not to because i'm a i'm the room
manager so that that's my big beef is
that i
i try to manage my rooms the way that i
want them to be because i've been given
that title but then it ends up
always being somebody else because my
plants always look great
until other people start touching them
does brian get
high so that's the thing is
no he typically doesn't
but my little sister
brought us these snack bins and she made
some pre-rolls and put them in there and
not a single one of us the employees
used any of them and he went out every
single day
on our breaks and he was useless when we
went back inside he was absolutely
useless
and that i think that is an issue in
itself because if you can't smoke and be
productive then you can't smoke when
you're working well he's you know
testing the inner mechanisms of the
product
and that's important when you're
developing
when you're developing the product
wouldn't you agree
if you already know what you're doing
and you can handle it but i don't know i
feel like if you're supposed to be
supervising and
you know
you're supposed to be the one that is
doing all this stuff and fixing the
plants my plants don't look good right
now they all look bad they look great
when i take care of them i take care of
them all the way up until they go into
flower the second they hit flower that's
when everyone starts taking care of them
and
it's done
well isabella we don't want to keep your
friends
waiting
so thank you very much oh you're sharing
this you're my best friend but thank you
thank you very much isabella bye
isabella good luck with everything
thanks for calling
[Music]
zach leaving you
zach leaves you with a uh with uh horn
and a a gesture of camaraderie to you
well thank you because i was deleted off
of the tick tock creator fund for
uh posting too many i don't know if i
would smoke weed on there they'll get
you but you'll get your bands yeah i was
going to guess it was because
some plant stuff but i got no plants
that's a tough business
all right isabel take care
you see you don't smoke weird
do people tend to think that you smoke
weird like do people more back not so
much now but but they used to i used to
smoke weed but i just don't like it it's
like i wanted to like it i kept trying
to like it and then ultimately i just
made a decision for myself that i don't
like it what what what was like the last
straw it was like the last time you got
high and you were like i don't like them
well
i would get very anxious and i've tried
it a lot of times over the years so it's
like oh i'm going to try it now
and it's just never it's never good
i don't like it do you you i get the
sense that you are a smoker you know
people always think that i'm high
because um we're a lizard thing but um i
i don't get i never i never get high
like while i'm like streaming right like
if i were high right now i'd be bad i'd
be terrible yeah i feel that i i feel
that but like after like late at night
i'll probably get high i wish i could do
that for myself because it seems so nice
dude i sealed i see like you know
they're like content creator whatever
people who like you see them get high
and then go do the thing i'm like that
must be amazing like to be able to do
that i i
feel like i have nothing to help me
unwind because i don't drink and i don't
smoke and i am envious of people that
have that yeah but i i don't enjoy
either and so i just kind of
but i don't enjoy being sober that much
either so i'm kind of in a perpetual
state of uh discomfort you know anything
that takes the edge off nothing
yeah
okay it doesn't take the edge off though
it doesn't take the edge off it's more
just like
it's like clipping my nails you know
right maintenance more than anything
else yeah understandable
yeah it's not like a hobby or anything
[Music]
i get it yeah you ever done ketamine
i actually haven't
sounds sounds like uh what do you think
is that a good one
down in the k hole yeah
you know unwind a little bit just
take a little k
seems like you need like a long weekend
for that
do you uh do you smoke uh like cigarette
you ever smoke cigarettes
um
i do uh from time to time yeah
vape guy i don't know no no vaping
i was gonna offer you a hit of i don't
know
actually you want to share a vape with
me i don't have a vape i was it was an
empty thing it was an empty promising
empty promise well
why'd you say it then
i just wanted to say something i think
um
and how does it feel now that you've
said it um
not that bad i went i sort of took a
risk and it didn't work out but then i
don't i don't feel like i'm sitting in
anything too terribly awkward right now
a big lie
i i do i do kind of wish i vape though
because the the flavors are like but do
you remember like a few years ago people
were just dying from vaping yeah they
would like explode they were just lungs
would collapse they would like hit a
vape and their lungs would collapse yeah
what was it dan it was like giant like
weird chinese knockoff vape juice with
like dangerous substances i think uh
if i remember correctly it was there was
vitamin e oil or something they were
using to like cut it to save on price
and that cause
which apparently you're not supposed to
vaporize and inhale vitamin e
yeah i could be misremembering what oh
the chats agreeing they're saying
vitamin e acetate yeah is what they were
putting in that car whatever it is it
don't sound good to me
oh it was knock off thc vape
oh it was that's right it was right yeah
so it wasn't actually like the the
nicotine vapes that were yeah that was a
scary time people that was like um
that was a scary time people were like
i'm just gonna hit this vape and die
it was a it was a
it was a hard time to be a vapor i
remember
let's take one more call let's do it i'm
i'm sweating
yeah do your makeup it's the the one
thing that [ __ ] up the paint is sweat
but you're doing pretty good it's just
all in my forehead you can see here
this is a little bit of sweat i got a
little bit oh it looks good no you're
good my body has like i think i've like
acclimated yeah well to it
yeah one thing also is i'm trying to
keep the shadow out of my face it seems
like your face is really
well shaped for it
like the shadow just stays out
and you've got like a nice mushroom head
too
he's still got a little bit of a shadow
yeah i still got but like i i do
sometimes feel like my head and body
like this is a one size fits all costume
it fits you really nice like around the
shoulders like mine puckers up but yours
fits like you were born for this role no
my body is fully you know designed
decked out decked out
i do wish i wish that i had like a
like i don't know if it's like a fan or
something a fan would be stupid but like
uh some sort of stuffing to
pop oh you could totally do that just
get some cotton stuffing yeah
for sure you could sew it in
oh that would be you should have 100 do
that i feel like i'd no
i don't know i don't know how to sew or
do it you would be hot though your dome
will get real
i've been running around in the desert
in this thing it's not that bad
right
all right let's take one more from james
23 has a story well i'll let him tell us
james had a friend that had phone sex
over discord james um listen
what can we do for you oh sure
james uh
well i'm really happy to be on the show
by the way gekko well i'm very happy to
have you on the show james i speak for
myself are you happy to have him i don't
know yet
right
i mean i'm happy okay that he called but
i don't you know know this we don't we
don't know enough about you yet
okay fair um
i kind of need advice from you guys
because look
uh a week ago i was on discord with a
friend of mine
we saw that one of our close friends he
was in discord he was just sitting alone
so we joined in on
um
we
thought that he was just afk but we hear
like
wrestling
and you know
moaning and stuff
and it turns out that he was having
phone sex with his girlfriend
so so he didn't know his sound was was
she in the room or were you hearing him
on the phone
and it was coming through the discord
accidentally he was he was like
facetiming his girl right
um and his mic was on over discord and
we were listening on the whole thing
so what
what
go ahead
okay he doesn't know that we know yet
so
do i tell him that hey his mic was on
and we literally and we literally heard
everything it's a little late for that i
think
do you feel guilty at all about the
listening james
no because i it was it was hilarious at
the time i was laughing my ass off with
my friend and um
well i i did i had an edible at the time
but so i i wasn't thinking clearly like
i was like oh maybe i sound like being
high or something yeah i don't see how
that's relevant are you but are you are
you blaming you've kind of violating
your friend's privacy on being high
no i think it would just uh i would say
it's more like his mistake than leading
the mic on because look uh like
literally three minutes later
we hear his grandma walk in and like
yell at him to do something
okay so what if i tell him like make
small talk next time i like talk to him
i'm like hey what was your grandma
yelling at you at the time and then just
let him like put two and two together
and figure out on his own
but if he figures it out on his own then
he will then figure out that you were
listening and that you didn't tell him
so it doesn't that doesn't really help
you
i think he
i don't know to be honest i think this
is more of like a laughing experience i
think it is you'll get a little bit
laughter well well let's
let's let's stew on this a little bit
uh how graphic was this conversation you
overheard
not that not like bdsm or like bondage
like over the phone but like
did any of you guys get hard when you
were listening
no no definitely that's that's weird
he's like he's been like my best friend
for a year so
do you have bond i don't know that you
can okay um
so he was in a room by himself
and then how many of you guys heard this
call
it was just me and one of our other
friends so two total and how long did
you listen to him
i mean the whole thing lasted for like
five minutes and did did he finish
there's like granted at first we didn't
know what was going on and then we heard
the girl over the phone and then we
started laughing i see
and and then and so but did he did he
did he finish do you know what i mean
can you hear like could you tell when he
finished like the climax of it i guess
no
no
because the next thing we heard was his
grandma walking yeah let him do
something
and then he came back and then he's like
oh you guys are in discord and we're
like yeah
so okay so you guys
by the time you understood what was
happening
you listened for how long after you
understood what was happening
probably like two minutes of laughing
and then his name and then nan came in
and ruined the mood
yeah oh
he probably had his junk out if nan
walked right in
did nan mention anything about like oh
put that away
you said i said don't remember
you don't remember
i don't think so we didn't hear the
grandma clearly
she speaks in different language so i i
don't know
okay i see she speaks a different
language a language you don't understand
yeah
and do any of your how many how many of
you guys were listening in how many were
there he said two he said two okay well
it's just me and then my friend and do
it how does your friend feel about it
does he feel bad at all for the
eavesdropping
no not at all he laughs about it
constantly it is pretty funny
genuine quite how would you feel like
i i grew up with these guys it's been
like 10 years i've known them okay um
so well i mean i i i've known my brother
my whole life and that doesn't
necessarily mean that i would want to
listen to him have
phone sex
how would you feel if someone listened
to you have sex would you be comfortable
with it
like if like if he were listening to you
how would that make you feel
i think that's also kind of funny
it's kind of funny that's kind of what i
was actually expecting you to say does
it would it turn you on a little bit to
know that like your friend was listening
no no wouldn't that's not a thing for
you
i'm gonna come no
do you find your friend or his
girlfriend attractive
no not at all actually don't even like
the girlfriend is it a possibility that
you are lying to us you find them
extremely attractive and you're masking
it by saying you thought it was funny
no i i swear to you guys
i don't think they're attracted can i
ask you a question what was funny about
it
i don't know it's like this guy's like i
don't know
it was just funny at the moment we were
laughing so hard like what like what was
funny about it what
i don't know i don't know how to explain
it it's just like a
friendship type of thing
like we laugh at stuff like this all the
time
it was probably just uh
that you were witnessing this intimate
moment and he didn't know so it was like
more like shocking maybe and that was
what was funny about it
how did you feel like um you know you're
when you are with your friend you don't
really get to like see or experience the
intimate side of them that they
reveal when they're making love and
maybe that right was funny yeah
hell yes
i guess that's a good way to put it so
okay so honestly from what i'm getting
from you guys i should just not bring
this up at all ignore that it
essentially happened
i don't i don't feel like we've
put that and i don't feel like that is
the answer that we've put out
so what would be the answer i should i
should never bring this up to him
or do you think i should like one day or
like maybe like in a year down the line
and be like hey well hold on the fact
the fact that you're even approaching
this as a sensitive topic indicates to
me
that he might be upset
or that you know that it's an
uncomfortable line you've crossed
exactly or else you wouldn't even call
in with it
jimmy i don't know what to say to that
right but do you agree with my analysis
yeah i do i guess that makes sense right
do you think he'll be upset that you
heard all that
i think he would be for like maybe a day
but then i think he he gets over things
fast like this
like i don't think he would definitely
will never like hold a grudge against
this
you know
do you remember anything specifically he
said that that struck you as funny
it's what it's what she said that we
kind of figured it out oh yeah what did
she say
i don't know if it's okay to say it go
ahead
well she said well we heard her over the
phone she's like just spit on it and
then that's when we figured out and we
started laughing so hard whoa
so nana definitely saw something
that's a little funny
spit on it well i mean just not like
that not that isolated but like their
grandma i mean that's like an american
pie sure the grandma
yeah spit in my mouth look in my eyes
spit on it what do you think she was
referring to when she said that
the
what the
the like is
as talk probably
right that's a good assumption sure
yeah that's a good guess right
is it is it eating away at you that like
you haven't told him
is it actually is it actively bothering
you on your conscience
no it doesn't actively bother me
but it's more like a thought in my like
what if i'm like drinking with him one
day and then i tell him like out of the
blue
is that worse if i'm you know drinking
and i tell him that or if i'm sober
doing that
you're so obsessed with these like
states
of like i was high when i did this i was
drunk when i did this just let it
it's not important
just tell him tell him tell him the
truth it seems like you want to tell him
yeah i i think he would be more upset to
find out you didn't tell him right then
be like you know what we went in i mean
the explanation makes sense to me up
until the point where you figured out
what was happening and then to the point
where you stayed after that is a little
odd but i will say
up until the point where you were joined
a discord room with your friend and
you're like what is he doing
and then when you realize they were
having so so that's easy to explain
up until the point where he stayed and
continued to listen
[Laughter]
it's honestly it wasn't that long like
it wasn't like a 20-minute long duration
it lasted two minutes and the first well
it lasted five minutes total but like by
the time we figured it out like the
first minute we were laughing really
hard about it and then next minute the
grandma walked walked in and said
something and then my friend came back
with it like a
another minute later i mean one way you
could broach you to say what did your
grandma say to you when she walked in
when you were
uh jerking off
yeah
i probably should have said that in a
moment but because i'm really curious
actually what grandma said personally
too me too yeah
because that might be funny because
she's she probably she's probably a
funny person nana yeah
maybe
she's experienced what language is it
that he speaks that you don't understand
arabic
arabic
interesting
him and tell him just tell him yes can
you call him now can you call him
can you put him on speaker phone
can you merge i just like merge yeah
yeah call him and then merge the calls
you know how to do that it does does he
know does does he know who either of us
are
yes well he knows he knows you ethan uh
i don't know if he knows gay that's okay
okay but like so so maybe this would be
an interesting uh situation for us all
to experience we'll stay quiet and let
you do the explaining and then if if
he's okay i'd like to ask some follow-up
questions that sounds great
do i tell him that like obviously i
could tell him that hey he's going to be
on a live stream yeah
yeah you should probably yeah definitely
yeah yeah
yeah okay all right let me see if i can
if he picks up okay we'll stand by
do you think he's gonna pick up yes i do
um
[Music]
i was curious if he was a mod on this
discord because that would kind of
influence it too because i've had
similar situations not where somebody
was having sex but when somebody
accidentally stayed on discord great and
i you know when it's our friend's
discord i'm one of the mods and so if
you know for example i've come in and
somebody was on there didn't realize
they were on there and they were arguing
with their wife which is kind of
uncomfortable
really great and so i i used my ability
as a moderator to disconnect him from
the call
um so if you have that capability oh go
ahead oh go ahead
hello okay
hi sorry so this is my friend brandon
hi brandon hello this is ethan klein
from h3h3 productions
and i'm uh the therapy gecko
what okay so uh your name's brendan
yeah okay so before we get
before we get to this i have to tell you
your friend has an admission
to make to you and we are live on twitch
right now so i want to get make sure
that you're comfortable with with this
happening live
okay
okay so uh so james go ahead james just
shared an anecdote with us
james is going to share that with you
now
and then we can have a conversation
afterwards if you're comfortable so
james i'll pass it over back over to you
hey um
last week uh
why was your grandma yelling at you
what do you mean
like
last last sunday
um
more specific baby don't dismantle you
something or you do something
how do you know my grandma was yelling
at me
well
um wait
when was this
last sunday
last sunday like when
you know when
um you heard her yelling at me
yeah
did you like did you hear anything else
are you serious bro it wasn't that bad
it really wasn't are you serious
it wasn't that bad
look it was it was me and the eric in
the call
does the gecko and ethan also know
and so
and so he he was wondering how to break
it to you that uh that he heard this
conversation
andrew are you glad that james told you
the truth
yes i am
and by the way because you're live i
just want to give you a moment to take
it in you don't have to do this you
don't have to do this you're on the spot
we're doing a live show i want to give
you the opportunity to exit this
situation if you want
no i'm okay i'm okay okay okay so okay
i'm happy to hear that so can we tell
you what so can you tell us what grandma
saw when she walked in the room
and what she said uh
well i was cleaning up obviously okay so
this was post
wow okay so james you did hear him
finish
oh my god
well james was uncertain about if he
hurt had heard the climax yes i did i
did finish yeah wow okay so james did
you were you aware of that
how was how soon after you finished did
uh uh
did the gram walk in
maybe like two minutes later
oh that's pretty good timing because
and how much had you cleaned at that
point when she came in how much was
remaining uh
maybe like there was like
30 percent left were you shirtless at
the time
were you like naked
and it was on you i mean that's quite a
predicament for grandma to walk into
i had to put pants on
wow and grandma doesn't knock she just
comes right in your room no
grandma doesn't knock she just comes
right in
no it just comes right in
when you say there was 30 left was it on
where was it was it on your
stomach on the couch
a little bit on like the floor on the
like the floors little it was on a bed
so
there was some on my on my chest yes
and then a little bit on the on the on
like the best frame and stuff so i was
like playing that
okay so now so now apparently james and
one of your other friends joined the
discord and heard this all go down so
how does that make you feel
so you guys were like spying on me while
i was happy
oh my god
okay
we gotta figure out what happened like
when we joined the disc it wasn't until
like when we heard like you know some
things from the facetime call from you
know
her
uh
that's when we put that's when we kind
of figured it out but then
yeah he heard everything he heard her
say can i can i tell him what uh you
heard her say
okay okay
yeah she heard your girlfriend or well
this other the significant woman in your
life say ask you to spit on it
oh my
god yes
do you do you foresee this
affecting your guys's relationship in
any way
or do you think you'll be able to move
past it and resume the status as the
shock is kind of like dwindling down
it's kind of kind of the the weirdness
is starting to settle in
[Music]
well james didn't think this would be a
big deal so james do you want to to like
explain
because to me what i said to james was
like
i understand you drew you joined the
discord and you didn't and you were just
going to join your homie were you in a
private room how how was he able to join
the discord room
no it was it was a public channel so i'm
like oh hey he's here and then you know
my other friend and i joined we were
gonna play a game
so you'd forgotten to disconnect pretty
much and you were on facetime yeah okay
okay so he so
so he was he was going to he wanted to
play video games with you but at a
certain point when he understood what
was happening uh he continued to listen
but he said he thought it was
did you hear anything else
besides the spit on it
no
are you telling the truth
yes i'm telling the truth
[Laughter]
james has been quite honest with us to
this point i believe i believe yeah as
well i think i think he's deep enough
that he would just are you are you
afraid that you heard him hear something
else
yes yeah what else you say
what is it you're afraid he heard
uh
well i did
she was uh i did tell her to shove
something somewhere
did you hear that james when you were on
the call
be honest
i i i swear i didn't hear anything else
[Music]
it's so awkward
um andrew oh my god
andrew
how do you think your girl how do you
think your girlfriend feels is she i
don't want to is she a girlfriend or
this person that you were facing
this person i was yeah pers okay this
this person that you were facetiming
with how do you think she feels about
this or i think she would feel she
knew that she was being listened to
i think should uh i don't think she
would take it well well let's not tell
her kind of private let's let's
definitely not tell her sure yeah i
think it's good
i think it's good that you guys know you
buddies know but let's not tell the girl
sure
yeah
okay oh my god yeah let's not tell her
so are you mad at james or do you for or
do you have any questions for james
really
well i'm not mad because like it's my
fault
from what i'm understanding yeah in a
way everything's together
yeah but
do you do you wish james
oh i'm sorry please go ahead
yeah go no you go ahead
i had nothing important to say
yeah i'm curious what your thoughts are
if you just want i just wanted you to
get it all out
uh
obviously yeah i feel weird that he he
heard me but
i also appreciate the honesty
from him at the same time
there you go
what did you ask her to shove
uh so if you have a
a
[Music]
a thing
that like women used to
pleasure themselves
right mm-hmm
was one of those
was it like in the normal hole or the
alternate hole
uh
was it wasn't a normal hole
okay nothing to be ashamed of there i
don't know look we've we've learned here
now the healing powers of honesty
well is there is there anything
is there anything you guys want to say
to each other before we uh
conclude this
hey man i'm sorry for like staying in
the call
and you know i love you
that's very nice
james even though
you creeped on me having phone sex with
this girl
he did that and now people on twitch tv
all heard us have this deep conversation
yeah it'll be on youtube as well
i just want to say uh i i forgive you
thank you i hope this doesn't get in
between you guys i really think james
was just
looking for some honest feedback for
what he did
and
got caught up in the moment and brought
you on so i you know i think james
really does care about you as a friend
and i hope that you can remember that
going forward as the road to forgiveness
i'm really proud of both of you guys
[Music]
do you feel like your relationship
perhaps has gotten stronger as a result
of moving past this
too early to tell it's worthy to tell
yeah
[Music]
i think i think i think it'll make this
stronger i think actually
that's awesome
and uh as i understand it as i stan as i
understand it you're uh
uh muslim or arabic and and so yeah
me being jew is i'm also uh circumcised
so i understand the need for spitting on
it
i'm jewish too yes
so you unders are you circumcised
so we have that in common
[Music]
and it sounds like you and your girl
have a really healthy um
sex life libido
yeah this seems like a new sort of
budding relationship and i'm i'm really
excited for you to see how it plays out
thank you
you're welcome
james are you circumcised
yeah
that's awesome
so you also understand the spitting on
it to act as a necessity
yes yes i do
right
as all do as all um
uncircumcised or circumcised man what
would for sure do not come
well guys listen
[Music]
wish all the best for you guys
really
and james the next time if you if you
walk in on your friend having phone sex
what are you gonna do
uh
probably leave the discord and message
him and be like yo
you're still in the discord bingo love
that character that's a that is such a
good answer
such a good answer
not just to leave but to warn
[Music]
69. lots of growth today
definitely lots of character development
here i i'm
do you do you each feel like you've
grown as individuals as a result of this
i know i've asked about the relationship
but how about you know your own personal
ability to be honest with people in your
life do you feel like that's grown
well i i think my ability to check if i
left the discord server or not has
definitely grown sure absolutely huge
never don't forget that one it's very
important
to come
[Music]
and i'm very happy that nana was none
the wiser
yeah because
i'm guessing nana would not have liked
that scene did you not lock your door i
mean how are you gonna how are you gonna
get it forget about discord what about
the door lock
i don't have a lock on my door
you better put a lock on that door dude
because you're two minutes away from
lifelong trauma
right oh my god she would have beat the
[ __ ] out of me
she would have beaten you up
[Music]
yeah would she have given you time to
put put your dick away
i don't know
we don't need to ponder on such uh
issues
[Music]
so thick
james are you seeing anyone do you have
a girl in your life
[Music]
no not really
okay here's a compromise andrew would
you listen to james having phone sex as
a way of equaling
the scoreboard that's a great idea
[Music]
i don't know i don't think so i think i
don't want him to also feel this level
of embarrassment
you wouldn't do that to him
so i wouldn't do that
but if he maybe left his discord
open on accident
and i happened to join thinking we're
gonna play a game
and i heard that
maybe i would stick around for a little
bit
okay so so maybe not as much uh growth
as we had uh thought
but not much has changed the beginning
of this
[Music]
well guys andrew and james i wish you
guys uh
years of happy gaming
and um
you know spit is not the most sanitary
lubricant so keep something nearby
that's not somebody recommendation no no
no no no
i learned that when i was very young
[Music]
yeah
yeah it's one of the first things you
learned really as a young
man exploring i used like axe body wash
oh burned it's all kinds of perfume and
[ __ ] and that that'd be bad bad bad bad
bad chemicals are not good for penis
all right guys
you take care now james thank you for
bringing this to our attention
good night guys thank you thanks for all
the help all right all right take care
guys thank you guys goodbye
well
people thought that was fake it was so
good you know at the end of the day i
always say you know
it doesn't matter if he was real or fake
we experienced it it was real though it
does matter it was real well because our
experience of that call
is the saying regardless of any events
that happened in the entire world
previous
so that's why the realness of it
ultimately
doesn't but
yeah the adoption of it is the same
but it was real but it was real yeah you
guys think it's a joke i was unsure
until he brought the friend in
unless the friend was like the best
actor in the world no that was 100 real
yeah
you know i i
props to both of those guys because you
get you you gave andrew the
like
some time to dip out if you really
wanted to yeah he could help through you
know
of course that was the right thing to do
you know you got to be like springing on
this live you got to be like you know
what dude yeah
you can exit this situation yeah yeah
but he he trucked on through
well we kind of did it for gecko talk
thank you so much for having me
gekko lyle forever we're gonna drop
links in the description he's on twitch
he's on instagram he's on tick tock
great highlights there thank you thank
you
this is wonderful it was nice did you
enjoy getting to speak with members of
your audience i did a lot you know it
was nice how did this go compared to
like i know you said you took calls like
two years ago or something like that
good is it is it do you feel like it's
gotten better no it's great i like it
yes it was very good people were having
great questions or great comments for
great questions the screeners did a
great job shout out to them
and thank you for everyone who was
calling and apologies to people who were
on hold who didn't get through obviously
we
didn't get to take all the questions so
you know
that's what it is
well guys we will uh this has been h3tv
we will be back
with families at the regular schedule
so peace and love peace and love
is this what we do
of course
thank you guys very much for for having
me this was very fun
all right
[Music]
you